today's new member of the day the
second-to-last new member of the day of
the year because it's the second to last
show of the year for us is Colin
Bulkeley Colin thank you for being a
supporter of the show today's longtime
sustaining member is Jamie Ainsley who's
been with us nearly five years joined
them at WWN pakman.com coupon code is
available saves you 40% this is 20/20
and if you want something extra special
if you want the biggest membership
discount of the year get on our mailing
list at david pakman.com a January first
email blast will go out with an
opportunity a single day opportunity to
take advantage of the biggest membership
discount of the year the David Pakman
show
has a discussion forum of sorts it's on
reddit at david pakman.com slash our EDD
i.t about 8,000 of our viewers and
listeners discuss politics there and
there were a number of interesting
stories I spotted this morning when
taking a look at the subreddit including
the news that Kevin Spacey is now facing
felony charges for sexual assault
a Massachusetts District Court has
issued a criminal complaint against
Kevin Spacey for allegedly sexually
assaulting an 18 year old multiple men
have come forward with accusations of
sexual assault and harassment against
Spacey you know Pat it started just with
the abrupt refilling and end of house of
cards because of allegations of sexual
assault against Kevin Spacey this has
now exploded and this is not looking
good at all for Kevin Spacey initially
the question was these are allegations
that seem to all exceed the statute of
limitations now you actually do have a
criminal complaint that's been accepted
in Massachusetts it's not looking like a
good ride into the sunset for Kevin
Spacey is it did you see the video that
Kevin Spacey put out a few days ago he
was in character as Frank Underwood
trying to dismiss some of the
allegations it was really really bizarre
I don't know if you've seen that that
sounds fun incredibly strange it was
we're and I didn't see that I'm gonna
look for that though so things are not
looking great for Kevin Spacey and it's
being pointed out on the David Pakman
show subreddit also from the sub
a post saying that there is a blinking
to an article in The Washington Post
which points out that Donald Trump's
campaign manager the new one is asking
people to call a hotline that's been set
up to say Thank You president Trump is
there anything more special snowflake
then needing to hear people leave the
voice messages praising you and thanking
you and of course the answer is we know
that this guy is an incredibly sensitive
special snowflake to take a term from
the right that I don't really use but
I'm using satirically because we know
that he gets his propaganda o´clock file
two times a day on normal days I don't
know if that frequency has been
increased of him just looking powerful
in pictures that have been used in media
and good lower-third headlines from fox
news and other right-wing media just
absolutely stunning that this is what
your campaign manager is even doing to
keep you sort of satiated having people
call in and leave voicemail messages
talking about how great you are just
absolutely pathetic and lastly from the
david pakman show subreddit Tom Hartman
says the United States states should
stay in Syria to protect the Kurds yeah
strictly speaking as I mentioned
yesterday it's a fallacy to say
something is right because X person is
saying it but at this point we should
consider why it is that people from the
left like Noam Chomsky and Tom Hartman
are saying even if we're generally
against United States military
intervention we can still point out that
the haphazard and erratic withdrawal of
US troops from Syria is not something
that makes particular sense and as I
mentioned both yesterday Noam Chomsky
and today Tom Hartman are of that
mindset some people emailed me and said
David you know you could just be against
military intervention regardless of why
it is that Trump is getting out getting
out is the right thing to which I would
say that's perfectly fine but you still
want to look into whether the guy's been
blackmailed or there is foul play right
I hope that the answer there is
join the discussion david pakman.com
slash re DDI t don't troll we have
moderators and they are fully deputized
to prevent trolling on our subreddit